ce film ne peut avoir qu'un effet
d'incitation on a envie d'aller
s'acheter sa première drogue dans le
quartier tout proche que pensez-vous du
problème de la drogue en général
nous sommes nous-mêmes drogués je n'ose
vous dire depuis quand
Christiane F ce drogue si on l'appelle
Christiane F et que je teste son nom
c'est qu'elle est mineur c'est même
encore une petite fille et là 13 ans
elle habite Berlin la drogue l'entraîne
vers la prostitution une tragédie
qu'elle raconte elle-même dans un livre
qui est aujourd'hui en Allemagne un
best-seller et dont on vient de tirer un
film qui va sortir en France où le livre
est également traduit c'est cette
histoire simple et terrible que nous
raconte Michel Meyer à Berlin à
proximité d'un mur aussi infranchissable
que tristement célèbre les façades d'un
monde bloqué se sont garnis d'un visage
d'adolescente
Christiane F c'est son nom est devenu
une tête d'affiche qui rapporte de
l'argent à ceux qui racontent sa vie par
le film et le livre
à Berlin au-delà du mur de béton
résidentiel qui sépare la ville du monde
de l'Est on est donc encore sous le choc
d'une révélation
celui du destin d'une jeune fille pour
qui ces quartiers de Berlin ont été les
étapes d'un sinistre calvaire avant
d'offrir leur sortie de métro pour la
promotion publicitaire du film qui en a
été tiré
le peuple de Berlin jeune surtout c'est
donc précipité
[Musique]
ce film tiré d'un livre reportage de
deux journalistes d'un magasin allemand
peut-être plus voyeuriste que sérieux
c'est l'histoire d'une fuite éperdue de
la jeunesse de Berlin c'est l'épopée
désespérante de ceux que l'on nomme ici
en anglais s'entend nos futurs people
les gens s'en foutus
parmi les compare c'est de cette
aventure de la nuit de Berlin il y a
Christiane F et son jeune ami Dethleffs
S
[Musique]
en échec ce sera pour Christiane F la
descente aux enfers de la drogue de
banovso traduire la gare du zoo de
Berlin
au bord de ce chemin la dépendance a des
drogues de plus en plus dures de plus en
plus irréversibles la drogue donc et ses
déchéances avec à la clé la prostitution
à 15 16 ans
ah on de l'âge de Christiane F et qui
habite le quartier de la gare du zoo ce
que montre le film fait partie de ce
qu'elle voit quotidiennement
ce film est en dessous de la réalité
dans ce sens il n'est pas bon car il
invite à la drogue plus qu'il ne
repousse de la drogue
à vrai dire et trois ans après que
Christiane fit soit perdu la gare du zoo
de Berlin est resté l'épicentre des
agressions et arrestations en tout genre
c'est un endroit aussi étroitement
inefficacement surveillé par la police
banovso c'est une gare où d'éternel
clochard attendent des trains qu'ils ont
irrémédiablement raté
man of zoo c'est aussi le synonyme
berlinois de la prostitution des mineurs
ainsi que dans les rues avoisinantes
tout continue à se vendre comme à
l'époque récente de Christiane F tout
c'est-à-dire des corps de femmes de la
drogue des Adonis des travestis et
autres transsexuels
triche traduire le tapin des bébés c'est
locataires ont été très touchés par le
destin de Christiane F
mais ces adolescentes restent fidèles à
leur poste et à des macros qui sont
aussi leur vendeurs de drôles à Berlin
comme ailleurs la prostitution est très
souvent liée à la drogue
[Musique]
sur la base d'une enquête très
rigoureuse ce film montre aussi
l'horreur du vol de drogue entre droguée
des scènes presque quotidiennes à la
gare du zoo de Berlin tout cela nos deux
interlocutrices le vivent et le savent
[Musique]
il est réaliste bien qu'un peu exagéré
c'est surtout le cas pour le rôle de
Dethleffs
le propriétaire du cinéma qui joue que
ce la gare du zoo et quant à lui très
satisfait comme le livre le film est un
succès total c'est qu'elles sont pleines
on vient de partout pour voir christiane
est on en est content nous dit-il et
c'est même le cas de ceux qui se sentent
concernés une minorité
notre homme finit pourtant par être
contesté abruptement par un vrai
spécialiste
ce film est une imbécilité
ça m'a dégoûté de voir comment les
spectateurs riaient de certaines scènes
il ne comprenait rien à rien
on a ridiculisé la vie de ce que l'on
montre dans ce film
ça Michael et
ation on a envie d'aller s'acheter sa
première drogue dans le quartier tout
proche
cela dit ce film ne dégoûte pas assez de
la drogue on aurait dû y montrer des
choses encore plus repoussantes
[Musique]
que pensez-vous du problème de la drogue
en général
nous sommes nous-mêmes drogués depuis
quand je risque d'avoir des problèmes
mais ce n'est pas d'hier
drogue à Berlin il paraît qu'il y aurait
des problèmes d'approvisionnement
c'est faux on trouve ici tout ce que
l'on souhaite tout est là où et quand on
le veut
voulez-vous en sortir avez-vous souhaité
d'en sortir
oui j'ai essayé de m'en sortir mais j'ai
toujours rejeté
ainsi malgré le livre et le film et pour
ces cristianes F sont non la vie
continue donc avec son cycle verrouillé
la prostitution pour l'argent qu'elle
rapporte et l'argent pour la drogue
le balai immobile des dealers et des
drogués continuent lui aussi de plus
belle dans un climat à peine conspiratif
dans l'attente de l'héroïne qui s'offre
ici à raison de 700 francs le grammes
des drogués se grattent vainement froid
qui leur va jusque dans le cœur des eaux
d'autres sont plus précises encore ils
vont rechercher dans les coins d'ombres
le goût amer de l'héroïne
[Musique]
nous en sommes ici à la vague des
drogues dures elle touche de plein fouet
les plus faibles ceux qui sont en
contact avec les travailleurs étrangers
en 1981 rien que parmi les 8000 drogués
de Berlin cette vague a déjà tué 55
personnes la police est naturellement
présente sur ce théâtre d'opérations
elle repère nombre de drogués et de
petits vendeurs mais les gros poissons
de la drogue restent pour l'heure assez
inatteignable
on continue et on continuera donc
d'assister à des autodestructions qui se
conclut très souvent en pleine rue par
des crises de manque et la chute d'un
drogué
[Musique]
le récit et le film sur Christiane F
sont des succès commerciaux des succès
en bigus car ils ont peut-être mis en
contact avec la drogue des êtres
fragiles vulnérables ce film montre
pourtant très clairement qu'en matière
de drogue tout finit toujours très mal
la mort est toujours au bout du voyage
même si Christiane F a été sauvé presque
par miracle et qu'elle vit actuellement
dans le nord de l'Allemagne l'année de
son sauvetage un sauvetage qui restera
provisoire toute sa vie 84 drogués sont
morts à Berlin
[Musique]